[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did everyone get a brownie there are
awesome brownies I mean if much sugar
crush a little bit but it's definitely
worth it I recommend if you haven't got
one so yeah
continuing our awesome Brad ladies block
here at the side track we have Monica
who is from the San Francisco and she
can be best described as creaming cat
face tada emoji
so please welcome Monica oh man I didn't
realize this was the lady's blog I'm so
much more excited mail so I'm super
happy about this talk because I get to
talk about three things that I'm very
excited about and that's emoji always
and art and web components which is like
a new thing that I've discovered I
really like and the only thing that
would make this cat this talk better
would be cats so here's a little tiny
one hi everyone I'm Monica I'm not
Waldorf on github and Twitter and
Internet places and I we're going to
polymer which is a library that helps
you write web components and I'm going
to tell you what web components are and
what polymer does later because now I
want to talk about art so before I
became a developer I was convinced that
I was going to be an architect because
all of my life I drew things and I
painted things I took courses and I
really like making art but it turns out
art is kind of hard so now in my
thirties I decided I'm going to take out
pottery and unlike painting and drawing
raising like stash things that you've
made under your bed my kitchen is now
covered in like tiny little pots because
I can make like cups that are human
sized yet because I don't know how I
just have like cups for dolls everywhere
and they're taking away all of my space
so art is kind of hard and it takes a
lot of practice and if any feel like a
talented painter like then go
this is a painting called bedroom and
Arlo's even if you're like you're
naturally talented you woke up and
you're amazing it still takes a lot of
effort because when you are that good
and you can draw anything that you want
you start having different problems like
oh my compositions all my colors are off
it doesn't express the thing that I
really want but this one time at
Christmas is like 15 years ago I came
home and my mom was like oh I got to
show you this thing that I discovered
and she shows me it's like amazing
painting that she painted of like a
landscape or a street in Paris that I
remember and the reason that this is
important is because my mother is not a
talented person she's not an artistic
person she can draw and I was like how
have you managed to produce this and it
turns out it was a paint-by-numbers and
that's what I realized that people
really enjoy making art even if they're
not good at it if you give them the
right tools so in this case thing by
numbers is really enjoyable if you're
not naturally talented
it's like restricts the problem to
something that's very small it tells you
what colors took wood where and at the
end you get this like awesome thing that
looks pretty and then you get to show it
to people because artists fun you get to
make things you get to like spend a
little bit of time and produce something
and sharing garde is really fun she
doesn't like make the painting and like
hide it away in the basement she showed
it to me and she's like look at this
thing that I made isn't it awesome I'm
van Gogh she's not
and we know sharing art is fun because
who here has raise your hand if you've
never taken a photo and put it on the
Internet yeah nobody everybody takes
photos and you put them on the Internet
all your friends see them there's a
whole industry of apps that's put
filters on your Instagram photos so that
they're pretty and artsy last years it's
like app came out it was called prism on
it and it made everything look like a
painting and it was like super popular
for like three weeks because we like
vacation we like making pretty [ __ ] and
being like look what I made look at my
artistic talent and you know what is
really good at sharing the web all of
these things are on the web's or in like
this fantastic cloud we have we don't
like print them out and give them to
people anymore
we put them on the web so I'm going to
show you some
things that I like about making like
making art on the webs they're like ups
that I've seen that go around so the
first one is something called octopus
Holdings so John I'm going to butcher
his last name ergun rotor from the
Research Center made this thing where
basically you just put words that
represent emoji in your URL and then
they get stacked so this is a cat
wearing the next tile using pants on an
elephant and it's Turtles all the way
down and it's really easy to share
because it's just an URL you give it to
people they can see what you made it's
very easy to understand so the tools are
very simple like the problem the the
problem of you making art is very simple
you can only just like use emoji and
it's gonna be amazing it's kind of fun
you get to like make dumb things what
else can you put in there it starts with
like their what the reason why it's
called anoxic withholdings is that if
you don't put anything it's like an
octopus holding a trophy that's kind of
Awesome Jennifer made this awesome make
a fit art project where it's like a like
paint from 1992 and you get to draw with
pixels so it's like simpler than me
giving you a pen and pencil because
that's kind of hard you have to like
figure out how hold a pen but pixels are
easier there's fewer of them you can
increase the resolution the colors are
more limited and it gets a like this is
my attempt to draw a cat and it's
terrible but the reason why I know it's
really fun and people really like it and
again people really like sharing this
art is that a lot of people will tweet
at her and be like look at this thing
I've used make a bit art to like work on
a game with my kids who's 6 and this is
amazing these are like kids using it
make it make it vid art to make art on
the web we're like exposing kids to
making art with code and technology
early on which is kind of awesome on a
similar vein my friend Lauren made this
thing called Meg emoji where it's kind
of also like making darts because it's
like a pixel drawer but instead of you
drawing with color as you draw with
emoji and it also takes this other
amazing tool that we have in the real
world like tracing so if you're not
really good at arts that you want to
draw something sometimes you like to
trace it on the different piece of paper
so this is a lot like that I had a
really bad day one so I spend like an
hour just making dumb [ __ ] this is a cat
that I've made out of the mode to using
Meg emoji it was really fun because it's
very simple I just try to trace the
katahajime
and now I'd like old circles out see
have like started with a things with
emoji and then into drawing and out back
to emoji
this is mojo brush that Sam ciccone made
and it's literally a brush that's emoji
and you just draw on a canvas that's it
that's all you do and it's really
awesome and a lot of people would like
use it to make dumb things with it I
think a key of she's a lady lead on
Twitter she like draw things with people
and like tweet them with them and be
like look I've made her portrait in moji
brush and again this is really fun
because it's a very easy and sort of
like joyful project to do so the reason
I'm telling you all of this because I
think we've made we're really good at
making arts more accessible to people
and more friendly by giving them better
brushes we'd like to learn this over the
years we have color by numbers we have
tracing we have all of these apps that
make they make it really easy for you to
create things and if you believe me that
that's true but I think the same thing
is true for the web the web can be made
more accessible and fun and by that I
mean making apps on the web can be made
more accessible and fun if you give the
web better brushes because the same
argument can be made for both to both
things and by better brushes I mean
something better than a div because I
like a doom but it's basically the pen
and pencil equivalent to the web where
you still like have to learn how to hold
the div and how to style it and how to
size it and vertically Center it and all
sorts of things like that so the web is
really good at semantics and in html5 we
got awesome things like header and nav
and article that tell you what those
elements do they don't look any
different they just look like you know
divs of text but they at least tell you
what they're supposed to do so he put a
header they should probably be at the
top and the article somewhere in the
middle and there's a footer at the
bottom and it if future you is going to
like reread this page it's going to be
much easier than if you had you know
just a pile of peas in these days where
hopefully you put a class equals header
somewhere so that you knew that like I
meant to put this at the top the other
thing that the web is really good at
is encapsulation and this is one of my
favorite things about the web so there's
like these magical elements that we have
in the browser that do magical things
like video or input input has like 21
different types it can view color
picking and it can upload files but you
don't actually have to wonder how
they're implemented they just like come
to you and you get to use them you're
like sweet this is amazing
but if you can actually look and peek
inside of you there's a flag in chrome
called
enable user agent shadows and you can
actually peek inside these elements so
input for example just the text the text
field has just one div in it it's like a
content editable div that's kind of cool
the moment you put something like type
equals number on it was just like a
number of Flickr they can go up and down
it all really becomes more complicated
it has all of these divs it has some
like pseudos in it so if you've ever
tried to style those like parts of an
input element and you're like you need
to do : : - WebKit - something that's
really come from that pseudo is like a
little bridge that you can reach into
this element and be like I really need
to spin to style the spin button and the
reason why this is important is because
these divs and these styles don't go
outside of the input element that's why
you can't just reach and style anything
in it you can only you can only style
things that like that element really
wanted to style and that's when
capsulation is awesome something like a
video element is actually ginormous and
terrifying
it's got like ranges and buttons and a
[ __ ] ton of divs in yeah so cool
encapsulation is really awesome
so if semantics are awesome and
encapsulation is awesome that means like
we can keep waiting and the web's going
to give us something like emoji brush
which is semantically expressive it's a
brush of emoji and it's encapsulated
because god knows how a I'm actually
implemented this nobody needs to know
we're never going to give it like the
blink team will never just let you put
an emoji brush in Chrome that's not a
thing we can do but that's what web
components do and that's why I really
like them they take this idea of
semantics and with encapsulation that
the browser already has and it's been
using it and giving it to you as
developers so that you can use it as
well and compose
themselves they're not special like
reactive components angular has
components but the reason why web
components are really awesome is that
their framework agnostic there is thing
that the browser speaks which means you
can write a web component in like
vanilla JavaScript and use it in the
react step use it in an embryo because
Thomas sitting right there suppose you
remember and they're really awesome
they're like they interact with
everything because you know the browser
language it's anywhere where you could
use an input you can use basically any
web component and that's awesome and
that's what I work on but let's talk
about art again because that's where we
talking about so if people we make arts
with brushes we like paint on things
they like trace things and we make
absolute components and the better our
brushes were the better art is or
they're easier or artists so the better
our components are the easier our apps
are going to be able to be built to so
wanted to show you
I built this really dumb app called
emoji light which looks like this so it
basically lets you upload an image and
then it's pixelated but it replaces
every pixel with an emoji and you can
take the resolution so you have more
more emoji or less emoji and then it's
alt text so you can like copy paste it
and send it to all of your friends
because you're going to love this but I
wanted to build it to tell you how I
built this out of web components because
I thought that was kind of fun so if you
look at this enormous app we have an
input type equals file which is kind of
like an OG web component so that's cool
we have some buttons all of these are
like normal browser stuff we assume
legal paper slider so this is an element
that my team works on paper is like a
code word for material design at Google
it was a terrible naming choice that
we're now stuck with forever but that's
like a fancier slider because if you
ever try to style a native input type
equals range it's like 150 lines of CSS
and the thousand pseudo-element so
that's like a fancier slider that's a
fancier checkbox that looks a little bit
pretty and then in the middle I have
this giant emoji light element and it
basically does all the thing it like
collect it collects things from the file
so it looks like the file content
and then collect things from the
configuration so like it's a number of
pixels you want on each side and stuff
like that and then every time they
change it gets updated and the reason
why this is important is because these
changes are really easy if you've got
like a data binding sort of system and
that's where polymer comes into play
because remember I told you or some
polymer so polymer is kind of like
jQuery and I'm trying to like pitch this
this the sentence about it so I think
polymer is kind of like jQuery for web
components not in the sense of like you
don't need it anymore and everybody
hates it and includes like seven
versions of it on their site but in the
sense that it's sort of like sugar is
the Dom where like it makes Dom
interactions a little bit easier while
waiting for the Dom to actually get
better because like 15 years ago or 12
years ago I used to write C++ I didn't
actually use jQuery but writing things
was kind of hard inserting child nodes
and adding child nodes and manipulating
the Dom was a little bit of a
frustrating experience and it didn't
work in the same way in all the browsers
so that was kind of a pain well polymer
right now what components are kind of
new and polymer gives you all this sugar
because I secretly hoped that one day
we're going to get like native native
data binding on the web and I keep
trying to pitch this to the blink team
but yeah the way they're binding works
is that if you look at this emoji light
element in the middle it has a file or
like file contents rather than a
resolution and then I have an input type
equals file at the top now we're
pretending here is that the input API is
actually sane and does something that
you want which it doesn't but if it
would have a value called some file
where it like contains the data blob
then you can just bind it magically and
be like well whenever this thing changes
just teleported over here the reason why
this is a lie is that you need like one
line of JavaScript to like respond to
the event setting for technicals file
fires but you know it's nice in our
dreams
the resolution works like that so - so
whenever that slider you move it around
and it's value changes then the
resolution gets up data and you can put
in your custom element and at this point
I haven't written any JavaScript I've
just written HTML and I've just used
data bindings because polymer sugared it
around for me so the same thing can
happen with the checkbox because one of
the things that module a ListView
you can show or hide the background of
your image to make it a little prettier
now let's talk about custom element so
this emoji late element isn't really
that weird and I wanted to show you that
it's like plot for me and not like this
weird code that you're not familiar with
there is two parts of defining a web
component you have to sort of provide a
prototype to write a class that says
what that element does and then you have
to tell the browser to associate a
particulars tab with that prototype so
that class is just a normal class that
extends HTML element and the second
thing at the bottom says hey browser
anytime you see emoji late and tags like
that just use that prototype over there
and our progress is going to be a good
time now with Palmer Palmer - so we're
going to you know it's the thing that
we're announcing at i/o polymer element
is an extension it extends HTML element
so it basically takes whatever you would
normally do and then add some sugar to
it and sugars and then wraps it all very
nicely that's what we call a taco
because what I really like to do is
write my HTML in HTML in my CSS and CSS
and not in JavaScript I'm really sorry
so one of the things that we can do in
polymer it actually provide what this
element looks like in HTML so this
element has a hidden canvas where I'm
rendering this pixelated image and has a
hidden image where actually loads the
file that you've given me and then I
output it to this logical content and
the code isn't very hardly to visit more
like special I have a properties block I
have like some properties this element
cares about like that file and
resolution and the checkbox row is
binding them and then I have this like
you know JavaScript functions and
whenever that resolution changes I can
call an observer and it just calls it
for me now
this isn't very hard you could write it
in vanilla JavaScript it's just like an
event listener and it's a getter and a
setter for a things called resolution
but if you don't need to write it you
don't have to write it and that's why
polymer does it for you again timeline
to currency just does the heavy lifting
for you that's all the code I'm going to
show you so let's talk about art again
how does it mostly actually work because
the pixel eats and as emoji to it and
that's why we have this dumb name but
the real interesting question was should
it use a canvas and treat you should
you span they're both going to look the
same in the end but I really wanted to
use a spin because we're going back to
this idea of sharing arts I really want
people to be able to share all these
like dumb productions they're going to
make with emoji late and if you have a
spam you can copy paste it and then you
know spend it on swag to all of your
friends and everybody's going to be very
happy because all of your history is
going to be blown forever and ever
my team's internal code name is Voltron
I don't remember who said I read this on
Twitter I thing like Sara IDO said this
recently where every project or every
team has at some point name something
internally Voltron and it's usually like
an awful combination of things that have
been looted together that's my team cool
so how do we actually emoji elite how
does the how does it actually work
well first thing we do is I load your
file and I put into a hidden image and
this is a the file is the image that I'm
using it's got lemons is cool then I
have to find its ratio because I'm going
to eventually print it out to a canvas
and that canvas has to be the right size
so that your image isn't super wobbly so
then I'm going to resize that canvas and
then I'm going to pixelate it and
pixelating is actually the easiest thing
to do on a canvas because it's basically
the thing we've all accidentally done at
some point in time or like you take a
really tiny image and you stretch it
down and print it out when it's enormous
and it looks like a potato that's it
that's exactly how he's pixelate you
just resize your original image to a
tiny little spot and then you stretch it
out and bam pixels now if I wanted to
just pixelated I could stop here we got
to get up with some emoji on it so I'm
going to divide this into a resolution
sort of grid so here the resolution is 8
because I have like 8 chunks that I'm
going to display across and then for
each of these chunks the campus API
actually gives you an array of every
single pixel in this file so all you
have to do is go through like a sub
array of pixels and calculates the
average color and then I've calculated
the average color of every emoji and
then I can just pick the emoji that's
closest to the color in that blob here I
have done very bad things due to RGB and
assumed it's linear it's not so I just
take a normal linear distance
it's not correct it's kind of correct
it's only not the best emoji for that
but I don't care it's ours we can get
away with this and then for every single
blob in this I'm going to keep doing
this and just put the put the spans in
my output so I'm just at the end you're
going to get a giant pile of fans all of
them containing an emoji that is sort of
the colors that used to be in that image
cool and because it's text you can copy
paste in and then send it and depending
on whatever font you're using it's going
to be warped because slack doesn't use
monospaced funds so it's like work
lemons but that's fine because you made
a thing and now we can show it to all of
your friends which is exactly where
we're trying to do in the first place so
and all that was made with web
components and because you can make my
components you should make like a more
awesome
artsy web components like a word art or
component from like Microsoft like
Windows 95 or Windows 97 I don't
remember which one came with like the
amazing MS word or a dart where you can
make these abominations and put them in
every presentation because they're cool
at the time we're going to be awesome
what we can do this with emoji so I give
you a text and you have like a
foreground emoji and a background emoji
and it says your text didn't use my
coworker implement to this so then he
has this this is like a custom element
that I've made to call like an emoji
picker so you pick your emoji and then
you put your text and then you get
awesome things and because it's it
what's important it's like semantically
expressive it was called emoji art you
know exactly what it's going to do and
you don't need to know how it works
because the implementation is also scary
so cool I want you to think of web
components like better tools that we can
help people make apps because that's
what they are but in particular I want
you to think of them as tools that we
can make people make art and share art
on the internet because that's what I
really care about so do things share
things tell people how to pixelate their
face and put emoji on them Thanks
[Applause]